[Music]
on this Wednesday night the race to
extinguish Nova scotia's Flames the
premiers please the Halifax mayor's
blunt message it'd be nice in a time of
Crisis if we could have no stupid policy
and why this year's Canadian Wildfire
season started early
a school field trip takes a terrible
turn could have been so so much worse
the accident that sent more than a dozen
children to a Winnipeg Hospital
troubling Trend why more kids are
getting the wrong dosage of their
medications and home away from home for
Sailors I've never deployed
having kids the struggles at Sea and the
Navy's new recruiting offer with no
strings attached
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
in Nova Scotia tonight raging wildfires
are all consuming thousands of people
have been forced to flee and some won't
have homes to come back to the number of
people facing that devastating reality
could grow in some areas the volatile
Flames are expected to spread there are
14 fires burning in Nova Scotia three
are out of control the premier says his
Province needs help and there's no time
to lose
we don't know all of the resources that
the federal government has at their
disposal but they do so now isn't the
time to wait and see wait wait for Nova
Scotia to ask this specific question or
this specific no there's not the time
for that it's time to to pitch in with
whatever you have
about three hours south of Halifax this
bridge on Port Clyde Road collapsed
after it was damaged in the Shelburne
County fire that Blaze is now more than
20 thousand hectares making it the
largest in Nova scotia's history
and just about 30 minutes outside of
Halifax the fire burning in Upper
tantalon has grown to 837 hectares
there's been widespread destruction with
at least 150 homes lost firefighters are
working grueling hours on the ground and
in the air trying to protect whatever
they can Mike Armstrong has our top
story tonight from upper 10 Talon just
west of downtown Halifax foreign
even from the air and even for
experienced Pilots fighting this fire
has been emotional speaking to some of
the people at the controls they've had
moments where they choked up looking
down at homes that have been destroyed
there's a level of Randomness the deputy
fire chief felt some of the same
emotions after driving Wednesday morning
through the evacuation Zone and
Devastation it's a site of tragedy it's
terrible to see there's you know this is
these are people's homes this is a
community
some members of that Community are being
allowed in police are leading small
convoys two or three cars for people who
left behind medication or a pet Victoria
Rockwell was trying to get home to pick
up a cat her dog is in her back seat in
the trunk some of her most precious
mementos things she grabbed in frantic
minutes Sunday on her way out the door I
just went upstairs and just took a bunch
and I had some pictures of my mom these
are my wedding photos
you know
um like my husband and I
now The Wider Community has been helpful
there have been so many donations of
things like toys and clothes they've
asked people to stop for now but
accommodations are a challenge for some
Lindsey Doyle's family of four has slept
in three different places in three
nights they've stopped unpacking it's
hard to to put words to it it's we're
kind of on autopilot right now and
feeling a little bit numb it just sucks
to know that other people's lost their
house
about that a lot yeah
province in that you're hoping to
bring to more there's a ban on all
activities in forests and even wooded
parks are now off limits there have been
small fires started by carelessness
Halifax Police tweeted a warning
Wednesday reminding people not to throw
lit cigarette butts out of vehicles it
would be nice in a time of Crisis if we
could have a no stupid policy but
unfortunately that doesn't really exist
that's why you have laws one thing
everyone here is watching is the
forecast there's the immediate concern
the Heat and the wind that might affect
the fire and then there's the question
of when relief might come there is rain
in the forecast Friday night that's
supposed to last for about five days me
through that is very welcome news here
that would definitely be welcome news
Mike Armstrong and upper tantel in Nova
Scotia thanks Mike
hot and dry weather across the country
means the Fire season started early
residents of Boca Back New Brunswick are
taking stock of the damage after they
were allowed to return home while
residents of Fort Chippewa had to flee
last night with little notice and the
hottest months of the Canadian summer
are still coming Eric Sorensen reports
on the fires burning across the country
and why things seem to be getting worse
the destruction from wildfires is
happening swiftly from the Northwest
Territories to Southwestern Nova Scotia
in Northern Alberta hundreds of
residents of Fort chippewan were forced
to evacuate with little notice from
their isolated Community some have begun
arriving in Edmonton a hot dry spring
from western Canada to the east coast
has seen more than 2 million hectares
burned so far this year 10 times more
than average in Southwestern New
Brunswick fires have swept in and
destroyed properties one Blaze encircled
but didn't damage Judy Johnson's home I
had no idea how bad the situation was
until I actually had a friend come and
they went all she could say was my God
your house is still there wildfires can
vary from year to year but what stands
out is how early all of this is
happening look how few fires were
burning this time last year the fire
danger was low to moderate the blues and
the greens over much of the country this
year the fire danger is high to extreme
the yellows and oranges and reds over
much more of the country and the number
of fires burning about 100 or so are
contained but dozens are out of control
and remember this is only may we haven't
even made it to June and June July
August are only going to get hotter
um and um have higher chance of fire
um fire danger building across across
the country
um from coast to coast to coast quite
literally the trends are evident in 2013
the 10-year average by the third week of
May 61 000 hectares burned annually over
the last 10 years by the third week of
May an average 157 000 hectares have
burned across the country more dryness
more heat and that will bring more
lightning sparking even more fires from
Individual homeowners to land use
planners at every level of government
Canadians will have to adapt using our
best knowledge to figure out how do we
create
defensible space around our homes and
communities is critical because we
already are burning down neighborhoods
climatologists point out that this is an
El Nino year with warm Pacific currents
that if anything will make western
Canada and the Western U.S even hotter
and more prone to fires later this
summer
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
in Winnipeg a grade 5 field trip to a
popular Historic Site turned into a
nightmare 17 children and one adult were
taken to hospital after a platform they
were on nearly 20 feet above the ground
collapsed Melissa ridgeen reports
a day intended to educate and offer
Adventure was never supposed to end here
in panic at the Winnipeg Children's
Hospital as parents rushed to their
children after getting a terrible call
and
you know as a parents I I couldn't do
this to stay home or kanipal's son was
one of the students most 10 or 11 years
old visiting Fort Gibraltar a local
historic site for a field trip about the
fur trade when suddenly classmates
became Witnesses we were on a bridge it
was like a fence Bridge
so then we walking and then the bridge
fell down and then there were three
people that got majorly injured and then
like 30 people fell we're not
identifying the children involved but
Hospital officials say most are now home
some after being treated for broken
bones one boy will stay overnight
needing surgery for a fracture
could have been so so much worse this
couple was still shaken after learning
their son wasn't hurt and I was just
worried about all the keys just make
sure everybody's all the kids are okay
investigators are now working to
determine what caused the race platform
to fall and when was it last inspected
this is a replica that was constructed
in 1978 so not as old as you might think
this site hosts tens of thousands of
visitors a year including for the
popular winter festival festival de
Voyager workplace health and safety
they've been here today they're going to
continue their investigation into how
something like this happened me too all
right Melissa ridgeen in Winnipeg thanks
Melissa
pressure is growing in Ottawa for David
Johnston to step down a special rump or
term the former Governor General ruled
out holding a public inquiry into
foreign election interference last week
while opposition leaders want him out
the decision rests with the Prime
Minister tariya isri reports
I declare the motion carried the vote
may be symbolic but the rebuke is real a
majority of MPS have lost trust in
former Governor General David Johnston
the house passed an NDP motion
urging Johnston to step aside a special
rapper tour and pressing the prime
minister to call a public inquiry prime
minister is not restoring confidence
with the decisions he's taking we need
confidence restored when Johnston was
first appointed the new Democrats
praised him I certainly trust him to do
his work two months later there's really
no reason now to continue with Mr
Johnson the reversal comes after
Johnston ruled out holding a public
inquiry into foreign election
interference ceases has informed at
least three MPS that the Chinese
government has allegedly targeted them
Trudeau is standing by the special
rapper tour and his recommendation to
hold public hearings instead it's
understandable that the political
parties uh want to make partisan points
on this but the fact of the matter is
David Johnston has served this country
in extraordinary capacities for decades
but opposition parties aren't convinced
and think Trudeau should have called a
public inquiry from the get-go the
question is
what the hell is he trying to hide so
much in his report Johnston calls for an
interference a substantial danger and
identifies major gaps in intelligent
sharing political experts warn partisan
bickering is distracting from the bigger
issue protecting Canadian democracy this
shouldn't be about David Johnson or even
about this report frankly and I think
again we're we're tracing rabbit tracks
as opposed to Big Game the vote in the
house was non-binding and in the end
prime minister Justin Trudeau is the one
who decides if Johnston can finish the
work he started despite the backlash the
special rapper tur says he still wants
the job
Global News Ottawa
Canadian consumers are spending more in
the face of recession fears as the
economy rebounded in a big way during
the first quarter of the Year Canada's
economy grew at an annualized rate of
3.1 percent from January to March
beating statistics Canada's forecast of
2.5 percent the agency attributes the
surprise surge to higher exports and
household spending however housing
investments slow due to an increase in
borrowing costs the bank of Canada's
next interest rate decision is expected
next week
a frightening commute for some Toronto
Transit Riders
[Music]
coming up fireworks causing chaos
chaos
[Music]
Toronto Transit officials are
investigating after disturbing video
surfaced on social media showing
fireworks being set off inside a crowded
bus people screamed and dumped for cover
there were no serious injuries the
Toronto Transit Commission is aware of a
couple of recent incidents and says
those responsible will be held
accountable
when a wave of viruses infected
Canadians last fall children's pain and
fever medication was scarce and families
were scrambling some hospitals told
parents cutting down adult medication
could be a temporary solution as
Catherine Ward explains a new report
shows that had some problematic
consequences
we saw a real risk of harm to children
related to the shortages it wasn't that
long ago families were looking to win
the lottery
[Music]
the pain relief lottery for kids
medications nothing is available at the
time organizations including sick kids
hospital in Toronto as well as the
Ontario poison Center offered
Alternatives one included Consulting
Healthcare professionals about how to
cut down adult medication for children
Dr El Cohen from SickKids says the
guidance was critically important if
anything probably reduced the risk that
was happening to Children and Youth who
were who were being administered adult
medications at the time at the very
least it provided safe guidance as to
how to do it a new report indicates
there was a noticeable jump last fall in
the number of calls about dosing errors
to Ontario poison Center which also
covers Manitoba and univit sometimes
they were trying to use adult
preparations or that they were having
friends bring product in from the United
States that didn't have the same
concentrations Dr Jonathan sapersky was
on the team that crunched the numbers
we found about a two-fold increase in
the number of calls to the poison Center
and that was when accounting for other
factors that might have influenced those
calls the good news is that we did not
find an increase in the risk of
hospitalization however expert would say
it does reveal the need for strong
Supply chains sheds light on the
importance of producing some medications
here and not only producing medications
at home but also building in systems
where we can increase production during
times of need we hope to not be in this
situation again
we reached out to health Canada for an
update on managing cold and flu
medication supplies but did not receive
a response Health Canada says on its
webpage ensuring that Canada's patients
can get the medicines they need is a top
priority Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
Health Canada is taking extraordinary
new measures to warn people of the
dangers of smoking new labels will be
printed directly on cigarettes Canada is
the first country in the world to take
this approach experts hope the effort
will help deter new smokers encourage
quitting and reduce tobacco-related
deaths
[Music]
unease in Ukraine ahead the growing
concerns over the safety of Europe's
largest nuclear power plant
oh
that is body cam video from a police
officer in Georgia he was investigating
a Highway crash when a car on the
opposite side of the highway drove up
the back of a tow truck launched into
the air and flipped over the driver
amazingly survived but their condition
is not known
the U.S has approved a new 300 million
dollar Aid package for Ukraine it
includes weapons and Munitions for
drones there are new fears over the
safety of Europe's largest nuclear power
plant with reports Russia is moving in
more military hardware and today again
troops pounded the Ukrainian Capital but
there was also another strike inside
Russia's borders as Crystal gomancing
Reports it's unclear who's ordering all
the attacks
an oil refinery burning in southern
Russia local officials say it was hit by
a Ukrainian drone an anti-vladimir Putin
group working in Ukraine freedom of
Russia Legion posted about the attack
but no one has claimed responsibility a
former CIA case officer and Global
Affairs expert says there are many
possibilities including a Russian false
flag operation or Ukraine testing the
waters for a bigger strike either way
the Kremlin May benefit when civilian
targets start getting bombed or blown up
or damaged by drones
that's scary people on Tuesday an
apartment Block near Moscow was hit and
two people injured while strikes inside
Russia are rare Ukraine is pummeled
regularly this dash cam video shows
debris from a Russian missile crashing
onto a car Monday in May alone the
capital endured 17 Russian aerosols
leading to praise from Western leaders
this is due to the Ukrainian commitment
and their ability
to be strategic
smart Brave and perfectly well organized
what the streets will look like when the
highly anticipated Ukraine
counter-offensive begins no one knows
but there are fears about the safety of
Europe's largest nuclear power plants we
are fortunate that a nuclear accident
has not yet happened Raphael Grossi
speaking at the U.N security Council
Tuesday proposed five principles for the
protection of the zaparizio power plant
including no attack on or from the plant
and no heavy weapons such as multiple
rocket launchers be housed there so far
neither side is signed on crystal
gabansing Global News London
All Aboard next an exclusive look at
life on the South China Sea
sailing over enormous stretches of water
can be a challenge for anyone that
includes the Canadians on board hmcs
Montreal Global News has been granted
exclusive access to a new military
mission in the highly contentious South
China Sea it's far from the Comforts of
home and easy to miss family and friends
but there are powerful ways to stay
connected and make healthy habits a
priority here's Mackenzie gray with a
rare behind-the-scenes look at one
sailor's life at sea
it takes a team
to pull off one of the toughest tasks on
HMC as Montreal
an aircraft maintenance Chief Andre
Crocker is a key part of it but when his
day is done
he returns to his tiny room he shares
with five others and despite the tight
Quarters here in the top pictures my
wife and I Crocker makes space for a
small reminder of home this is the first
time I've been away from them since
they've been small I've never deployed
having kids
that deployment on March 26th the dreary
day in Halifax but Global News was there
to see the ship off and to speak with
the crocker family sad to see him go and
like know that he's not going to be
there for such a big portion it should
be okay I think it is going to feel
weird though we're at least having him
more or less around the new experience
for us the family
watching back an emotional moment that's
definitely good to see them
even though it's not life
but what Crocker can't see his
daughter's cheerleading competitions he
missed while at Sea luckily enough we do
have internet I get some videos but uh
it's it's not the same as being there in
person here we're up here on the boat
deck which used to be one of the only
places you could get Wi-Fi but just
today they installed a new high-speed
internet system which will make face
times and texts much easier for Sailors
on a six-month deployment being away
from family for that long is one of the
many reasons the Navy has struggled to
get fresh recruits leading them to bring
in a new program offering new Sailors a
one-year contract with no strings
attached well short of the usual
three-year agreement and retention is
also an issue I'm going to come back to
Halifax again but that's not the problem
for Douglas Curry I'll be retiring soon
after we get back just because I can't
do the things I want to do anymore Curry
is The Montreal's coxman think of him as
the ship's principle I never expected
you know all those years ago to reach
this Rank and be in this position what
will he miss the most I'm going to
really really miss
the the great people that are on board
and the great people and that I've met
over the last 30 two years the Navy says
they got over 200 applications for their
new program but that's just a small dent
in the 16 000 new members the Canadian
Armed Forces need
Mackenzie gray global news on board hmcs
Montreal in the South China Sea
and tomorrow McKenzie takes us to the
sky for a special mission on one of The
Montreal's most valuable assets the
Cyclone helicopter
that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm nitu Garcia today is World
otter day so we're showcasing the sea
otters at the Vancouver Aquarium rescued
as orphan pops and deemed unable to
survive in the wild they live now at the
aquarium thanks for watching have a
great night
thank you
[Music]